hello
and welcome to lesson three of the
business analytics foundation with our
tools course offered by simplylearn
after completing this course you will be
able to
get a basic introduction to r
understand exploration of data
explore data using r
visualize data using r
understand diagnostic analytics
implement diagnostics analytics using
are
understand the concepts above with the
help of case studies
let's start our lesson with a basic
introduction
to r
r has become one of the most popular
tools for data mining
let's see why and also gain some basic
knowledge
on
r r is a freely available programming
language for statistical computations
and graphics
it is published under the gnu public
license
it is mainly used in the fields of data
mining and statistical analysis
out of its various applications
it includes time series analysis
linear modeling and non-linear modeling
the main advantage of using r
over other such tools for data mining
is its active community
the built-in packages and the package
contributions by the members of the
community
another reason for its popularity is
that r needs very little programming
knowledge
you can download r from its official
website
r
dash project dot o r g
the website has instructions on how to
download and install r and the basic
machine requirements
r studio is an ide for programming in
our
that is freely available
it is completely optional for you to
download our studio
the programming in the following
chapters will be taught using the r
command line prompt
if you are using rstudio you can type in
the same commands as shown in the
chapters
finally you are strongly encouraged to
check the community forums on r as you
go through this lesson
to answer basic questions and to explore
the different functionalities
of our
in the next slide let's start with a
very basic introduction to the commands
in are
getting into the specifics and
statistical analysis in r
listed here are a few important commands
that would be used throughout the course
to use a particular package
the install dot packages function is
used
this installation needs to be done only
once
once installed the functions can be
loaded into the current session by
calling the library function
r comes with a set of built-in sample
data sets
which we would be using in our lessons
this data can be loaded using the data
function
and the syntax is data of data set name
to use external data
the read function is used the write
function writes data from the r session
to a file
r's default directory is the user's
documents folder
it can be verified by using the
get wd function
to change the working directory use the
set w d function
with the full path name as the argument
in case the working directory is not set
the full path name needs to be specified
for read and write functions
for example read dot csv
of
c colon front slash
r tutorials front slash sample data dot
csv
note that r uses the forward slash for
specifying directories
the assignment operator in r is
different from the equal to operator to
assign a value to a variable in r use
the lesser than dash symbol
for help on any function in r
type question mark followed by the
function name to open the r help text
if you are using r
the help text will open on the default
browser
in the next slide we will look at the
basic exploration using r
before getting into the functions and
commands for data exploration
let's look at how data is stored in r
the data in r is stored as data frames
which are a tabular representation of
the rows and columns
there are other types of data as well
including table
matrices
vectors
and single values
in our course we will primarily use data
frames and time series data in the later
chapters
in the slide you can see a sample data
frame
the iris data set is a very popular
commonly used data set introduced by sir
donald fisher
the data contains 150 entries
belonging to three different species and
includes features such as
sepal length and width and petal length
and width
the three species have 50 entries each
as shown in the data frame
each row denotes a particular case or in
this context features of a particular
flower
the column denote the different
attributes measured
in the next slide we will look at
different commands to view data
let's start with basic commands view
data in r
throughout this lesson we will look at
commands and screenshots of r that will
display a sample output
you are encouraged to pause the video
and try out the commands on your command
prompt for better understanding
the iris data set is loaded by default
in r
to view the data set just type the data
set name on the prompt
to view the top few records use the head
function
the syntax is head of
data set name
comma number of rows
the number of rows is an optional
argument and the default number of rows
is six
to view the last few records the tail
function is used
the syntax is similar to the head
function
tail of
data set name comma number of
rows in the next slide we will look at
commands to view the dimensions of data
here are a few commands to view the
dimensions of a data set
dim of data set name
gives a vector result of the number of
rows followed by the number of columns
and col of data set name gives the
number of rows
and n row of data set name gives the
number of columns separately
try these commands with the sample iris
data set
in the next slide we will look at the
attributes of the data frame
to view the column names of a particular
data set type
names of data set name
to view all attributes type attributes
of data set name
given here is a snapshot of the two
commands of the iris data set
you can see that the column names are
displayed as strings in the first output
attributes displays the column names row
names and the data type of the data set
the class command is used to display the
data type of the argument
the syntax for class command
is class of variable name
for example class of iris would be
data dot frame
to know the type of a particular column
type class of iris
dollar sign
sepal
dot length
the dollar sign is used in referencing
the columns of a data set
in the next slide we will look at
viewing columnar data
data the column
following two notations be used
as mentioned in the previous slide data
set dollar sign column name would
display the particular column
another way is to use a matrix form
that is
data set of space comma column name
instead of the column name the column
number could also be used
in this case
petal length is the third attribute
hence iris of space
comma three
would also give the same result
in the next slide we will discuss
viewing row wise
to data
data of particular rows can also be
viewed using the square brackets
the format is
data set name
of
row numbers comma space
to display all columns or data set name
of row numbers
comma
column name or numbers
to display particular rows of particular
columns you can see the screenshot for
the subsets using square brackets on the
iris data set
also note if a single column or row is
displayed the output is in default
vector form
this concludes viewing data and
exploration in r
you are advised to try out all these
commands on your r or r studio for
better understanding
next we will look at a video to
illustrate the commands we have used so
far
this video shows all the basic
operations that can be performed on r
and will help any layman to use r
efficiently
we start off with one of the very basic
operations that help us to load and
install any package that is not
pre-installed in the r workspace
step one
this operation is called install dot
packages with the package name within
double quotes
two
a pop-up opens that asks for the server
to which you should connect to download
the package
xero cloud at the beginning is enough to
download the package
selecting that and clicking on ok
downloads and installs the package
step three
then the package needs to be loaded onto
the workspace which we do by using the
library function
once that is done the features of the
package can now be used for our purpose
step four
next we try to load a data set that will
be frequently used for all the analysis
that follow
this is the iris data set
and you load it using the data function
data of iris loads the iris data set
onto the workspace
step 5
now we shall do some basic analysis on r
just note that before doing any analysis
it is safe to save the data set onto the
workspace
that we try to use by using the attach
function
so attach of iris will save the data set
onto the workspace
step six
once done we can remove it from the
workspace by using the detach function
that is detach of iris will remove the
data set from the workspace
step 7
first we load the data set into a user
defined variable say
my data using the assignment operator
less than dash
which is less than sign followed by a
hyphen
we can also use the equal sign instead
both work the same way
step 8
now that the data is loaded into the
user variable
we can check the structure of the data
using the head function
entering head of my data returns the
first six records of the data set
step nine
now the screen is pretty full and we
would like to clear it a keyboard
shortcut comes in handy at this point
and that is control
which clears the screen of the current
workspace
step 10
next we look at how to check and change
the current working directory
the function get wd
returns the current working directory we
are in
and the function set wd
helps in changing the working directory
which we pass as argument to the
function within double quotes
the next function that we are going to
look into is the read function in r
along with the type of files that can be
read
step one
read dot csv
helps us to load a csv file
the path for which we need to pass as
argument to this function
we load the data set stored in the file
into a user variable
and then check the structure using the
head function
step two
we can even make a data frame of this
data by using the data dot frame
function and passing the red dot csv as
an argument or we can even pass the user
variable that stores the data as an
argument
step three
just like the head function we have the
tail function
that shows the last six records of a
data set
tail of the data set returns those
records
step four
we can display as many records by
passing the required number as an
argument after the data set name
so
head of my data
followed by a comma and then the number
of records you want to view returns
those records many from the start of
that data set
next we check four more basic functions
of r
namely dim
and call
and row
and names
step one
the dim function returns the dimensions
of the data set
that is the total number of rows and
columns
run the command dim of data set name to
get the required result
step 2
the end call function returns the total
number of columns and the n row function
returns the total number of rows in the
data set
run the commands and call of data set
name and n row of data set name to get
the corresponding results
step three
lastly the names function returns the
title of all the columns that are there
in the data set as usual run names of
data set name to get the column names
data manipulation
moving on to viewing row and column data
the following techniques are possible
column data can be viewed in three
different ways
first technique
call the column name after the data set
name using the dollar sign
that is
data set name
dollar column name
second technique
call the column name as a matrix
attribute of the data set
that is
data set name then within the square
brackets enter comma followed by the
column name with double quotes
third technique
this is similar to the second technique
with the difference that in place of the
column name within the square brackets
we need to enter the column number
row data can be viewed in the following
way
enter the row number followed by a comma
within square brackets after the data
set name
we can view multiple rows by entering
the first and last row of our choice
separated by a colon
in the next slide we will look at the
summary functions
this function is a generic function in r
that displays stories of data or models
as we will see in later chapters
the syntax is summary of data set
as shown in the screenshot the summary
function displays the minimum value
maximum value
mean median and first and third
qualities of every numeric data for
categorical data like species it
displays a table of the different values
and their frequencies
the table can be displayed separately by
giving table of
data frame
dollar sign column name
look at the example
table of
iris dollar sign species displays a
frequency distribution of the three
different classes
note that summaries for individual
columns can also be obtained by using
the summary function
and giving the referenced column name as
an argument
for example summary of iris dollar sign
sepal dot length
would display the results of sepal
length column alone
in the next slide we will look at a list
of commands for the individual summary
statistics
the summary function displays all the
summary statistics for a particular data
here you can see a list of commands to
display individual summary statistics
the argument for each function is the
column name
for which the statistics is to be
obtained
the commands are
min to get the minimum value
max
to get the maximum value
range
to get the range of the data
that is maximum minus minimum value
mean to get the average value
median to get the median or middle value
iqr to get the interquartile range of
the data that is the difference between
the first and third quartiles
sd to get the standard deviation
var
to get the variance
in the next slide
we will look at ways to aggregate data
in r
next we use the summary function of r to
get an overall snapshot of the whole
data set
step 1
summary of the data set name returns the
mean
median of each numeric column and the
frequency of levels of every categorical
column
there are various other functions that
can be used to separately analyze all
the columns in the data set
they are as follows
step two min
min of column returns the minimum value
in that column
for example when we do a min of the
sepal length column of the iris data set
we get the value 4.3
which is the lowest value in the column
step 3
max
max of column returns the maximum value
in that column for example when we do a
max of the sepal length column
of the iris data set we get the value
7.9 which is the highest value in the
column
range
range of column returns the range of
values in that column
for example when we do a range of the
sepal length column of the iris data set
we get two values
four point three and seven point nine
which tells us that the values in the
column lie between these two extremes
step five
mean
mean of the column returns the average
of all the values in that column
for example
mean of sepal length returns the value
5.8433
which is the average of all the values
in simple length
step 6
median
median of a column returns the central
value of by position in that column
for example
median of sepal length returns the value
5.8 which is in the middle of all the
values in that column
step seven
iqr
the iqr of a column returns the
interquartile range of that column
giving us a sense of the difference
between the upper quartile and lower
quartile of the values of that column
iqr of the sepal length returns the
value
1.3
step 8
standard deviation
the function sd is used to find the
standard deviation in a column of the
data set
for example sd of sepal length returns
the value
0.8280661 step nine
variance
to find the variance in r we use the
vare function
silver of sepal length returns the value
0.685
having finished all the basic
statistical function in r we now move to
aggregating the data set at hand
the data set is one of the few important
data manipulation functions in r
parameters that need to be passed into
the aggregate function are formula for
the aggregation data set used and the
type of aggregation
that is a mean aggregation or a sum
aggregation
aggregation in r can be done using the
aggregate function in two ways
the two ways differ only in the formula
that is used for the aggregation
step one in the first way we do it
across the data set by a particular
column
like the iris data set we can aggregate
across the data set by species
step two
for this scenario we enter the formula
as dot tilde followed by the column name
which is species in our case
the enter data equals iris for
specifying the data set and last give
the type of aggregation that is mean
or sum
step three
in the second way only the formula
differs such that the aggregation is not
done across the data set but only on the
variables or columns used in the example
with this we come to the end of the
basic operations that can be performed
in our
right from data viewing to data
manipulation to basic statistics
next we'll focus on the visual aspects
of r
in the next slide we will look at the
functions to visualize data in r
the aggregate function is used to group
data values of a particular column
the compulsory arguments are the formula
for aggregation and the function for
aggregation
the first argument aggregates all the
columns
as denoted by the dot symbol
grouped by the value of species
the next argument mentions
that the data belongs to the iris data
set
and the last argument specifies that the
aggregation should be done by averaging
the values
you can see the result has three rows
one for each class
and the mean values for each column
the second command aggregates only the
simple length column by species
belonging to the iris data set
in addition to the mean function the sum
function is a commonly used statistic in
aggregation
you can see the other available
functions by typing a question mark
followed by aggregate to see the help
content
next we will look at a video that
illustrates summary statistics
is a generic function used for plotting
data in r
the function can be used to plot a
variety of graphs on a variety of data
including data frames time series and
even vectors
the plot function creates a scatter plot
by default
other plots can be created using the
type attribute
you can check the help section for more
details on the plot function
shown here is a plot of iris data
on plotting the data frame it creates a
pairwise data plot for all the
attributes in the data frame
in the next slide we will look at a
simple scatter plot
the function can be used to create
scatter plots of one variable against
another
for example
let us plot sepal length against species
we will use a few optional attributes of
the plot function
main
to specify the title of the plot
x-lab
the x-axis label
y-lab
the y-axis label
the function would now be plot of
iris dollar sign sepal
dot length
comma
iris dollar sign species comma main
equals iris data
comma x lab equals sepal length
comma
y lab
equals species
the output plot is shown on the right
from the scatter it is easier to notice
the differences in the sepal length
according to species
next we will look at pie charts
pie charts are the simplest form of
visualizing the numerical proportion
of the different classes through the
sectors of the circle
the pi function is used to create pie
charts in r
the table function is used to create a
frequency table
and then the pi function is called to
create a chart of the table
the main attribute as mentioned before
is used to specify the title for the
chart
here is an example chart showing the
different species of iris data
the circle is divided into three equal
sectors for the three
species in the next slide
we will look at bar charts
bots are used to depict values in
vertical manner
with the height being equivalent to the
value that's being shown
for this example we will use another
built-in data set
us personal expenditure
the data set is displayed in the table
it displays the personal expenditure
data for categories across years
1940 to 1960
in r bar plots can be created using the
bar plot function
as with the plot function the main
xlab and y lab attributes can be used
for labeling
this slide shows an example function to
create a bar plot using the expenditure
data and on the right the created bar
plot is shown
in the next slide we will create box
plots
plots are used to show numerical data
with their quartile ranges
also called a box whisker plot
the boxes show the interquartile region
with the middle line equal to the median
the whiskers show the lower and upper
quartiles
and the points show the outliers
the box plots are very useful in
detecting the outliers
in r
box plots can be created using the box
plot function
let's see the example function displayed
on the slide
the first attribute shows the features
to be plotted
that is
sepal length against the species
the data
and the labeling information
on typing this into the r prompt
you will get a graph similar to the one
shown on the slide
you can see that there is an outlier in
the virginica species
in the next slide
we will look at histograms
grams are used to depict free
distribution data
r has a default islands data set that is
best suited to create histograms
once you are done with this slide
you are encouraged to try creating a
histogram using the island's data
in r histograms can be created using the
hist function
the first attribute gives the vector or
data frame to plot
and the usual labeling attributes can be
used to label the plot
it can be seen from the plot that the
sepal length is mostly concentrated
around
4.5 to 6.5
for numerical data such as simple length
the data is put into buckets and the
histograms are created
this slide concludes data visualization
in addition to these attributes plots
can have other attributes such as x and
y axis limits
colors for points or bars or lines etc
they can be found in the help section
for each plot
next we will look at a video that helps
in understanding the different commands
used in visualizing the data
basic data visualization in r can be
done using the plot function
step one
when we do a plot of the iris data set a
separate window pops up showing a
scatter plot across each and every
variable of the data set
step two
if we want a plot of any particular
variable or set of variables then we
pass the variable or column names as
argument to the plot function
for example for plotting the sepal
length across species we give the simple
length and species as the arguments
separated by a comma
here the first argument is the x-axis
argument for the plot and the next
argument is the y-axis
step three
next we can generate a pie chart in r
using the pie function along with the
table function
in our case we use the species column of
the iris data set
and pass it through the table function
to get a frequency table of all the
species which is then used to generate
the pie chart
so we enter the pie of table of species
and get the pie chart as output
step four
further we use the bar plot function to
generate the bar plot chart and in our
case similar to the pie chart scenario
we enter bar plot of table of species to
get the bar plot chart
now
for the box plot function
we need to pass a formula specifying the
variables that are required to be
plotted
say for example sepal length tilde
species
and along with that we enter the data
equals iris separated by a comma
and then try to generate the required
box plot
step six
the final basic visualization function
that comes to use is the histogram plot
generated using hist function
the basic argument that needs to be
passed is the variable that we want to
plot
in our example we just need to pass say
the sepal length and we get a histogram
plot
we can fine-tune this plot by passing
the main chart title
x-axis
titled and y-axis titled using the main
x-lab and y-lab arguments in the plot
function
and this can be done in case of all
other plots
in the next slide we will look at a case
study to understand what we have learned
so far
now take a banking related data set as
an example for doing data exploration
officer david from the sales department
has been asked to do a study on the
overall performance of a bank by
entering the bank loans
as part of the investigation david has
asked his colleague to categorize the
loans as seasoned or bad loans
with respect to age category
the following data categories have been
captured
age group
total number of loans
number of good loans
number of bad loans
percentage of good loans
percentage of bad loans
in the next slide
we will have a look at the data
here you can see a table of the bank
loan data
as mentioned in the previous slide the
number of good loans and bad loans has
been tabulated
as per the age category
there are 15 categories of age in the
table
given the total number of loans and the
number of good and bad loans
the percentage of good and bad loans has
been tabulated
in the following video
we will look at different statistics and
graphical visualizations for the data
let us start by exploring the data
since it is a pre-loaded data set in r
we will not be using any read command
however if you wish to save it to an
excel file
use the right dot csv command
the right dot csv command takes two
arguments
the data frame name and the name of the
file you wish to write it to
for example
dot csv of empty cars comma motor trends
card data dot csv creates a file motor
trends car data in the current working
directory with the given data
step one
first let us view the data set
type mt cars to display the whole data
set
we learned the concept of data frames
earlier
let us find the class of the data set in
r
type class of mt cars and hit enter
from the output we can infer that the
data is stored as a data frame
step 2
let us confirm the number of columns and
rows in the data set
type dim
of empty cars
the output shows 32 and 11 separated by
a space implying that there are 32 rows
and 11 columns
step three
let us explore the data in detail
use head of mt cars to display the first
six rows
though we already established the types
of the variables let us confirm it by
looking at this data
we can see that
vs and am have either 0 or 1 values and
thus have been rightly classified as
categorical data
the number of cylinders gears and
carburetors has discrete numerical
values and the rest of the data are in
continuous numeric format
step four to look at all the types of
cars type attributes of empty cars and
press enter
the first section gives the column names
which we have already discussed
the second section has row names which
consists of the model names of all 32
cars
finally the class of the variables
displayed
that is data frame
step five
let us find what all values that the
variable number of gears can take
type empty cars dollar gear
all the values of the column are
displayed
you can see that the values three four
and five are repeated in the data set
similarly you can check the number of
cylinders and carburetors too
step six
suppose you would like to know the
attributes of a particular car
for example the ferrari dino
we will use the format to view the road
data here
type mt cars of ferrari dino and a comma
within square brackets and press enter
you can now see the attributes of
ferrari dino displayed in a single row
step seven
now that we have explored the data we
will now look at summarizing to get some
meaningful insights before doing this
let us first convert the data type for
verses and am to factor
they are numeric by default
to convert the data type use the as dot
factor command
type mt cars
dollar am equals as dot factor of mt
cars
dollar am do the same for the versus
variable as well
step 8
getting into the summarizing part as
seen earlier type summary of empty cars
to display all the summary statistics
from the first section we can infer that
the maximum miles per gallon is 33.90
and the average is 20.09
the minimum miles per gallon is
displayed as 10.40
similarly we can note the maximum
minimum and other statistics for the
rest of the numeric data
for the categorical data the number of
entries in each group or category is
displayed for example from the am column
it can be inferred that out of 32 cars
19 are automatic and 13 are manual
step 9
what if we need to know which car among
32 gives the best mileage
the which dot max function is used to
return the index of the maximum value in
the data set
for example type empty cars of which dot
max of empty cars dollar mpg and a comma
the which dot max returns the index of
the maximum value for mpg variable
and attaching that with the mt cars
variable displays the row with the
maximum value for mileage
you can see that toyota corolla has the
maximum mileage in the given set of cars
step 10
similarly the row with the minimum value
can be found using the
which dot min function
let us find the lightest car in the
given set of cars
type mt cars of which dot men of mt cars
dollar wt and akama
we now know that the lotus europa is the
lightest of the cars
step 11
the commands mentioned now can thus be
used to find the maximum or minimum of
any variable and the corresponding card
data
you are encouraged to try different
combinations to get meaningful insights
step 12
as a final exploration technique let us
try the aggregate function
suppose we would like to know the
average mileage of cars that have three
gears
we will use the aggregate function to
aggregate the mpg variable by the
variable gear
and the aggregation function would be
average
type aggregate of mpg tilde gear comma
data equals mt cars comma fun equals
mean and press enter
the output consists of two columns the
number of gears and the mean of the
mileages
we can infer that the cars with three
gears have a mileage of 16 on average
the cars with four gears are the best in
terms of mileage giving the highest
average mileage
the aggregate function can similarly be
used to find the average speed of manual
in automatic transmission vehicles and
so on
following mathematical exploration
techniques we will now visualize data
and try to support the inferences made
through the earlier commands
step one
let us start with a scatter plot that
includes all the factors in the data set
being plotted against each other
type plot of my data
and hit enter
the new window shows a plot with all the
variables plotted against every other
variable in the data set
step two
but this gives a very generic plot of
all the variables and it is hard to make
any useful inferences from this plot
suppose we want to know how the
horsepower is related to the
displacement
let us use the plot function with the
formula hp
tilde disp to get the corresponding plot
we can infer from the scatter plot that
the horsepower increases even though
gradually as the displacement increases
you can see one data point that might
occur as an outlier
the horsepower is quite high for a large
displacement vehicle
this shows that there are other factors
that have an effect on the horsepower
step three
let us perform a similar plot for the
number of cylinders versus the mileage
the formula for the plot function will
be mpg tilde
sil
you can see the number of cylinders are
four six and eight
and as the number of cylinders increases
the mileage decreases and the effect is
quite visible
this plotting can be done across every
combination of variables and such
inferences can be obtained
though it is statistically possible to
create plots for any two variables
during a case study it is advised to
understand the data before plotting them
for example a plot of employee id versus
age in an employee database will work in
r but will not help the researcher in
getting any meaningful insights since
they are logically unrelated
step four
let's work on the categorical variables
we have the am variable which has two
values zero for automatic and one for
manual transmissions
the summary statistic will show us the
number of automatic and manual cars
but if we have thousands of data it will
be difficult to obtain a ratio of the
two categories
you can graphically view the ratio using
the pie charts as seen in the previous
lessons
we will use the pi function
we will create a table of the am
variable using table of empty cars
dollar am and pass it as an argument to
the pi function
from the chart it is seen that almost 60
percent roughly are automatic cars in
this case
step five okay now let us do a very
simple pie chart plotting
let us consider plot for am data
am is for automatic or manual property
of cars
so if it's needed to find if number of
automatic given by one is more or less
than number of manual the simple plot
can be done
so type some name of the data frame say
auto to extract the data of am in the
data set of empty cars
so type equals empty cars dollar am
then it's needed to make a table so make
another data frame to assign table for
auto
then for the pi plot type pi of matic
and now from the pi plot it's evident
that the number of manual is more than
the number of automatic
step six
similarly create a pie chart for the
number of gears
here the table should be created for mt
cars dollar gear and past the pi
function
we can infer that almost half of the
cars have three gears
the other half is distributed between
four and five geared automobiles with
the cars having five gears being the
least number
step seven
the continuous variables can be viewed
using box plots as we have seen earlier
let us create a box plot of the
horsepower grouped by the number of
cylinders
the formula for box plot will hence be
hp
tilde sil
and mention data equals mt cars and pass
them as arguments for the box plot
function
you can see that the horsepower
increases as the number of cylinders
increase
for cars with eight cylinders there is a
lot of variation as can be seen from the
wider box and whiskers for the plot
out of the three cars with six cylinders
have very less variation
though there seems to be an outlier as
seen by the dot in the graph
it can also be seen that the median or
horsepower for cars with four and six
cylinders do not differ much
step eight
let us look at a few bar plots and try
to make sense of the graphs
suppose you want to know the number of
cars grouped by the number of gears to
know this use table of mt cars dollar
gear to create a table of the counts
and pass this as an argument to the bar
plot function
from the plot we can find that maximum
number of cars that is fifteen cars have
three gears
and twelve cars have four gears and five
cars have five gears
similarly
this can be done for the number of
cylinders
type bar plot of table of mt cars
dollar sill to view the plot
here we can see that most cars in our
data set have eight cylinders and the
lease cars have six cylinders
this inference from the bar plot can be
done for all discrete grouping factors
step nine
as a final descriptive statistic
let us make a histogram plot for the
horsepower of the cars
to display the histogram type hist of mt
cars dollar hp
the histogram divides the horsepower
into buckets of 50 units starting at 50
and ending at 350 thus having six bars
we can see that most cars fall into the
100 to 150 horsepower range and only two
cars have horsepower of above 250.
this concludes the case study on
descriptive statistics using r
in the next slide we will discuss
look at the function to test the
equation between two variables
correlation is a class of statistical
relationship between two variables
that forms any form of dependence
for example
is there a correlation between the
height of parents and their offspring
in the example given we try to find if
there is a correlation between the sepal
length and width of a flower
in r
correlation can be calculated using the
core dot test function
by default the function calculates the
pearson's correlation coefficient
let's look at how to interpret the
results
the output shows the correlation method
used
and the data
the important output for this test is
the p value
which is calculated using the t
statistics
and degrees of
freedom as seen in earlier chapters
if the p-value is less than 0.05
we can conclude that the null hypothesis
is rejected
that is there is no correlation between
the two variables
the correlation coefficient is given as
0.1175698
this means there might be a negative
correlation between the two variables
but since the p-value is quite high
we conclude that the result is not
significant
that is
the correlation is almost zero
next
we will look at a video to understand
correlation using r
in this video we perform a correlation
test on two variables on a data set to
ascertain the significance of the
relation and values of the variables
we will use the anorexia data set from
the mass package for the correlation
load the package by typing library of
mass
specify mass in capital letters
we will use two variables of the data
set to perform the test that is pre wt
and post wt
run the command core dot test of pre wt
separated by a comma
the output shows name of the test that
is pearson's product moment correlation
in this case followed by the t value
degrees of freedom and the p value
then it tells you about the alternate
hypothesis which in our case is the true
correlation is not equal to zero
next it shows the ninety five percent
confidence values of the correlation and
finally the mean of the correlation
values
in the next slide
we will look at a correlation case study
in slide
let's look at a case study illustrate
the concept of correlation
the business case we have chosen is
about an ice cream company which
maintains a database containing total
sales per day and the corresponding
temperature each day
given this data for a period of one week
the management wants to find whether
temperatures is a factor that causes
difference in their sales
looking at our data set we can infer
that there are two
variables sales and temperature
here sales represents the value of total
sales that happens in the ice cream
company each day
and temperature represents the
temperature that is being recorded for
the corresponding day
measured in celsius
we will be using correlation to check
whether there is any relationship
between sales and temperature for this
company and the following video will
walk you through the process
firstly save the data into a csv file
step one
import the file in r
as seen earlier use the read dot csv
command to read the csv file with the
file name given as arguments
step 2
save the data set in r as my data
step 3
to check for the data in the data set
type my data and press enter
the data will be displayed and you can
check if the data has been stored
properly
the data will have seven entries across
two columns
before working on my data attach the
data set my data to the session by
typing attach of my data
step 5
the correlation coefficient is now
determined by using the command core dot
test
we need to supply the variables as
arguments
so type sales comma temperature within
parentheses and hit enter
step six
the correlation result is displayed
it can be inferred that the pearson's
product moment correlation test has been
performed
the test can be changed by using the
method attribute
the t value for these two variables is
calculated as
6.6333 the degrees of freedom is 5
and the p value is given as 0.001173
the basic alternative hypothesis is
displayed and the 95 percent confidence
interval is calculated and displayed
pearson's correlation coefficient rho is
displayed in the last line
and equals
0.946
from the earlier lessons we know that a
positive sign in the correlation
coefficient implies they both are
positively correlated
that is an increase in temperature leads
to an increase in sales
the value is close to one
which suggests that the association
between the two variables is very strong
in the next slide we will discuss this
of variance
anova
is used to compare the means between
different groups
here we show a simple example of one way
anova to illustrate this we use the
insect sprays data set
this data contains the insect count
after using six different sprays
here the null hypothesis would be that
there is no difference in using
different sprays
aov
takes the first attribute as dependent
variable
and independent variable separated by
tilde
here it is aov
of
count
spray
the data attribute specifies where the
data is to be taken from
after fitting the aov model the summary
function is used to display the result
it can be seen that the p-value that is
the last column is lesser than 2e
minus 16
which is the least positive number
represented by r
since p value is almost zero
we can reject the null hypothesis
and thus the inference is that there are
differences in results on using
different insect sprays
next we will look at a video that shows
how to perform anova in r
now let us perform anova in r using the
insect spray data set
for anova a model needs to be fitted
where we have to decide on a target
variable and one or more independent
variables
step one
in our case let's take count as the
target variable and spray as the
independent variable
step two
for fitting the model use the aov
function and save it in a user defined
model name say fit
so fit equals aov of count tilda spray
followed by passing the data that is
insect spray separated by a comma
step three
to check the model details run the
command fit
step 4
the result shows a table containing five
major columns that are in order degree
of freedom sum of squares mean squared
error f value and p value for each of
the independent variables used in the
model
finally the significance of the
variables can be checked from the p
value in the table and the important
variables can then be used for further
advanced modeling
in the next slide we will look at a case
study
let's get a case study for better
understanding of anova
a pharmaceutical company has tested
three formulations of a body pain
medication for athletes
27 volunteers were selected and they
were split into three random groups
nine members were assigned randomly to
each of the medications
the athletes were instructed to take the
medication while experiencing body pain
and then report the pain on a scale of
one to ten
ten being too much of pain
here the table shows the pain rating for
each athlete across each
medication the question the company
wants to answer is
is there a significant difference in the
effect of the different medications
since there are more than two different
groups
we will use analysis of variance to test
the significant differences between
means of all three medications
and the following video will walk you
through the process
to start with save the data into a csv
file
step one
import the file into r
let's name the file as my data
to read the file type my data equals
read dot csv
of the file name within brackets
make sure the file is in the current
working directory
and if not type the absolute path of the
file with forward slashes to separate
the directories
step two
check if the data has been imported by
typing my data to display all the data
alternatively you can use head of my
data to display the first six rows
step three
to apply r's anova function the data has
to be in a single vector format
to do so let us first convert the three
columns of data into a single vector
use the c function to do the conversion
after attaching the data to this session
that is using attach of my data type c
of med underscore 1 comma
med underscore 2 comma med underscore 3
save it in a variable let us name it
pain rating
now type pain rating to see if the
vector has been properly stored
step 4
now the medication type for each entry
data needs to be specified
create a vector that consists of the
value medication one for the first nine
entries
medication two for the next nine
and medication three for the last nine
entries
let us save it in a variable called
types
the rep function can be used to repeat a
given string for a given number of times
for example rep of medication 1 comma 9
will create a vector that has medication
1 repeated 9 times
to create the types vector type c
of rep
of medication one comma nine comma
rep of medication two comma nine comma
rep of medication three comma nine
you can now type types on the prompt to
check if the vector has been created
properly
step five
finally a data frame has to be created
that contains the medication type and
its corresponding pain rating
let us save the data frame in a variable
called body pain rating
type body pain rating equals data
dot frame of pain rating comma types
you can see the data frame by typing
body pane rating to view the whole data
frame
you can notice that this frame contains
two columns
pane rating and types and consists of
twenty seven rows
now we have the data frame ready
step six before using anova let us
visualize the data in a graphical format
we will be using the plot function to
plot the ratings as a function of the
medication type
type the command plot of pain rating
tilde
types
comma
data equals body pane rating and hit
enter
the box plot of the ratings is displayed
in a new window
note that there is an outlier on the
medication two rating entries
it can also be noted that the median for
medications two and three are the same
and the median for medication one is
significantly lower than the other two
let us now get back to the command
prompt
step seven
as seen in the earlier video the aov
function is used to perform analysis of
variances on the data
the formula for aov function should be
pain rating
tilde types
which implies that the grouping is done
per the types column
let us save the result into a variable
named anova result
type anova result equals aov of pane
rating tilde types comma
data equals body pain rating
to view the results we use the summary
function
type summary of anova results to see the
results of the test
step 8
from the previous results you can see
that the value of f statistic is 11.91
with a p-value that is equal to 0.003
since the p-value is significantly lower
than the standard value of 0.05
we can infer that the null hypothesis
needs to be rejected
in the context of this study we can
conclude that different medication
formulations have different impacts on
the pain rating for athletes
in the next slide we will look at the
squared test is used to calculate the
goodness of a particular fit
it compares the observed values against
expected values obtained from a null
hypothesis
here we try to test the sepal length for
goodness of fit
the low p value suggests we can reject
the null hypothesis
we will now look at a video to
understand how to perform a chi-squared
test
in r
now we go about doing the chi-square
test
for this test we need a categorical data
set and r has that kind of data
pre-installed in it
the data set is called hair eye color
step one call that data set using the
data function
run the data
data of hair i color and it becomes
active in the workspace
step two to handle the data more
efficiently save it in a user defined
variable say my data and put it in a
data frame
step three
then do ahead of my data to have a look
at the data set
step four just to make things a little
more flexible attach the newly made data
set my data to the workspace
step five
after clarifying the structure of the
data set do the chi-square test
step six
next for doing the chi-square test we
select two variables from the data set
say here and i
and run the command kisk dot test
of hair
comma i
after running the test we find that
these two variables are not at all
related and have no significance between
each other
suggested by the p value which is equal
to one
step seven
hence we move on to choose another set
of variables and take hair and freak for
the test
this time we find there is some amount
of significance between these two
variables suggested by the p value which
is equal to
0.06 very close to the 0.05
significance level which is generally
used as benchmark
in the next slide we will look at a case
study
t tests are used to check if there is
any difference in paired values
for example
marks obtained by a student before and
after a training
to illustrate this the anorexia data set
from the mass package is used
the data contains pre-treatment and
post-treatment weights of patients
to implement it in r
type
t
dot test
of
proot
comma
post wt comma
paired equals true
the first two attributes are the
features to be compared
and the attribute paired equals true
specifies that it is pairwise t test
the low p value suggests that the null
hypothesis can be rejected
that is
there is a difference between the
weights before and after treatment
in the next slide we will look at
independent t-test
the independent t-tests are used in
comparing two values where the value of
one variable
is not directly related to the other
variable
for example marks of students in two
different schools
here we implement a t-test on the sepal
length and sepa width
of the iris data set
from the result it can be seen that the
p-value is almost zero
and hence the null hypothesis
that there is no relation can be
rejected
now we will look at a video that shows
how to perform t-tests using r
next we try to see how to do t-tests in
r
starting off with the one sample t-test
use the anorexia data set for this
purpose
step one
choose any variable of the data set to
perform the test
say pre-wt
step two
run the command t dot test of pre-wt
and pass the parameter mu equals three
separated by a comma
the mu parameter corresponds to the null
hypothesis
step three
the output shows name of the test which
is one sample t-test
followed by the t-value
degrees of freedom and the p-value
step four
that tells you about the alternate
hypothesis which in our case is the true
mean is not equal to three
since we passed three as the value for
the mu parameter in our test
step five
next it shows the ninety five percent
confidence values of the variable and
finally the mean of the values of the
variable
next we do the independent t test also
known as the two sample t test
step one
choose any two variables of the data set
to perform the test
say
pre wt and post wt
step two
run the command t dot test of pre wt and
post wt separated by a comma
step three
the output shows name of the test that
is welch two sample t test followed by
the t value degrees of freedom and the p
value
step four
then it tells you about the alternate
hypothesis which in our case is true
difference in means is not equal to zero
step five
next it shows the ninety-five percent
confidence value of the combinations of
the variables and finally the means of
the values of the variables
now we will do the pairwise t test
step one choose any two variables of the
data set to perform the test say
pre wt
and post wt
step two run the command
t dot test of pre wt and post wt
separated by a comma followed by the
paired parameter which must be entered
as equal to true
so to tell the test that you are trying
to do a pairwise test
step 3
the output shows name of the test that
is paired t-test followed by t-value
degrees of freedom and the p value
step four
then it tells you about the alternate
hypothesis which in our case is the true
difference in means is not equal to zero
step five
next it shows the ninety five percent
confidence values of the combinations of
the variables and finally the mean of
the difference in corresponding values
of the variables
in the next slide we will look at a case
study
a construction company took a project of
building luxury residential apartments
in phoenix city
the project head andrew decided to make
an analysis on other residential
apartment constructions nearby phoenix
in order to avoid management
difficulties and to easily compete with
their competitors
so he asked his colleagues to collect
all relevant information that helps him
in finding useful insights
he wants to find all the business
insights possible so that he can compete
with all other competitors
and also avoid taking much risk in terms
of decision making and investments
his colleagues started collecting
relevant data
for this he did a survey of various
construction sites in and around the
locality
the final data that he collected
contained information on 12 variables
id
local price
bathrooms count
area per square feet
living space per square feet
garage count
rooms count
bedrooms count
age in years
selling price material and level let us
assume that you are the analytics expert
in the company and have been assigned
the task of working with the data to get
insights
now we have the data gathered and ready
for analysis
the first step that needs to be followed
is to import the data into r
for the purpose of analysis and easier
access to the data
we will store this data in a time frame
and name this data frame as my data
so type my data equals read dot csv
and give the path for the file
we will see the first six data entries
and check if we have chosen the correct
data set
to do so we typed head of my data and
the first six rows are displayed
now let us jump into the analysis
the first thing we do to start off with
analysis is descriptive statistics of
the data set
we get this in r by typing summary of my
data
now we can see the summarized
information of each and every variable
in the data set
we have the minimum value the maximum
value and first and third quartile value
the median and the mean value given for
each of the variables
let's see for the bedrooms count
variable
we see that the apartments have a
minimum of zero bedrooms which might
correspond to studio apartments and a
maximum of seven bedrooms
the median value is three
specifying that apartments with three
bedrooms are the most common
the first quartile as we know is the
middle value between the smallest number
and the median of the data set
for bedrooms this value is three
similarly the third quartile is the
middle value between the median and the
highest value in the data set
for the bedroom count variable this
statistic is equal to four
the mean is almost three
again showing that the apartments in
this locality generally have three
bedrooms
the individual summaries can be obtained
by using the dollar sign as we have
already discussed
if we observe the summary data we will
find that material and level don't have
the usual statistics like the quartiles
mean or median value given for them
they are instead classified into their
types and the number of occurrences of
each type
we can see that most houses are brick
houses
having the highest count and aluminum
wood houses are the least common
from the level variable we can see that
a majority of the houses are two-storied
there are only three ranches and seven
split-level apartments
and the rest are all two-storied
so constructing a two-story department
would be a very safe bet in this
neighborhood
however obtaining the summary of my data
doesn't give us information of other
important statistical terms like the
standard deviation variance etc
this statistical information is
important to make further decisions and
for analysis
though r has individual statistic
functions like the sd
var functions to obtain these values we
will use a library package to obtain all
the statistics
r has a package named pastix that can be
installed by using the install dot
packages function and included in the
current working session by the library
function
we use the stat dot desk function to
obtain a comprehensive statistical
summary of the data
so we type stat dot
desk of the data frame
that is my data in this case study
and here we can see statistics like the
number of values number of nulls number
of n a values the range of values in the
variable the sum of all the values the
standard error of the values from the
mean the confidence interval mean for a
95 percent confidence level the variance
value the standard deviation value and
the coefficient of variance
let us look into the statistical
description for a particular variance
say garage count and understand these
factors
the first row
nbr dot val give the number of values
that is 57
the nbr dot null value is 6
which means there are totally six
records in our data set that have a
garage count of zero
then
nbr.na shows a value of zero which means
that there are no not applicable
situations
the next row is minimum value and it
displays zero
so that means there are houses with zero
or no garages
the max column shows a value of two
so their maximum number of garages in an
apartment is two
next we can see the range
range is nothing but the difference
between maximum and minimum value
we can say that there are a zero to two
garages in the apartments belonging to
this locality
next factor is sum
and the value displayed is 73.
so in this locality there are 73 garages
the next is median and its value is one
for garage count that is most apartments
have one garage
we have a mean value of 1.28 however we
cannot take the literal interpretation
since the number of garages must be a
whole number the next factor is standard
error of mean
it is usually estimated by dividing the
sample estimate of the population
standard deviation by the square root of
the sample size
next factor here is confidence interval
mean
when we compute a confidence interval on
the mean we compute the mean of a sample
in order to estimate the mean of the
population
for our example the standard error and
confidence interval mean do not add much
meaning to the interpretations so we
ignore these values
to understand these values let us
analyze the selling price variable of
our data set
the selling price of apartments in the
locality varies from 13 million to 84
million dollars
the standard error mean here is 1.69
million
the confidence interval mean for a 95
value is twice the standard error
that is 3.4 million
we know that we are working on a sample
data set
the mean of the sample data of
apartments is around 34 million
what the confidence interval tells us is
that we can say with 95 confidence that
the mean of the population will vary
between 34 plus or minus 1.69 million
that is
32.31 to 35.69 million
next we have the variance of the selling
price
the variance is quite high as you can
see here
164.38 the standard deviation is 12.8
million
this logically makes sense as we have
our data ranging from studio apartments
to partial apartments with six bedrooms
and the prices of these apartments will
have a large variation
and the last factor we can see is
coefficient of variance
this shows the percentage of variation
from the mean
for the selling price it gives a value
of 0.37
that is there is a 37 percent variation
of values around the mean
let us view the selling price data in a
histogram
type hist of selling price
from the results we see that there are
buckets of 10 to 90 million
increasing by 10 million each
most of the houses are sold in the 20 to
40 million range and there are no houses
sold in the 60 to 80 million dollar
range
there are two apartments sold above 80
million
we are interested in knowing what is
unique about these apartments
to view just these two records we will
subset the data
type my data of
my data
dollar selling price greater than 80
and comma
two records are displayed
we know that wooden houses generally
have a higher selling price
also the count of rooms is pretty high
for these two apartments
the first data has a very high age value
and might have sold higher because of
its vintage value
now let us find the variations in
selling price according to their number
of rooms number of bedrooms etc
as seen in the lesson we will use the
aggregate function for this purpose
we attach the data frame to the session
by attach of my data
now let us aggregate first by number of
bedrooms
type aggregate of selling price tilde
bedrooms count and specify function as
mean
we get the corresponding average selling
price for each number of bedrooms
we can see a steady increase in selling
price as the bedroom count increases
from one to two bedrooms and four to
five bedrooms there is a jump in the
selling prices
apartments with three or four bedrooms
have almost the same average selling
price
the apartments with five bedrooms have
the highest selling price
so apartments and people in this
locality are willing to pay more for
apartments with five bedrooms
we should also remember that both
apartments that sold highest had five
bedrooms and thus the average results
might not be the right statistic due to
the presence of outliers
let us do a similar check on the selling
price according to the garage count
there is a huge difference between the
average selling prices of apartments
with no garages and two garages
so adding a garage might be beneficial
in increasing the selling price
the next thing that we would be doing
with the data set is to see which factor
is actually affecting the selling price
of the apartments
that is whether the pricing is affected
by the house material or the number of
rooms or the living space per square
feet etc
so to find out the variables responsible
for pricing we will do correlation
the correlation will tell us about how
much the variables correlate with each
other and also with respect to the
pricing factor of the houses
here another thing to keep in mind is
that in our data set we even have
variables which are categorical
as we already know correlation can only
be performed on numerical values and
cannot be performed on the other values
so how do we go about solving the issue
with the categorical variables
one way to go about this is to manually
select the numerical data
there is an easier option too
that is we can specify an attribute to
the correlation function which states to
select only the numeric values
the function laplay of x comma function
f returns a list of same length of x
after applying the function f on each of
the data item we will use this function
with the is
dot numeric function to remove
non-numeric values
so
let's type core
of
my data
of unlist of laplay of my data common is
dot numeric
so now we can see the correlated value
of every numeric variable with every
other numeric variable in the data set
apart from the material and level
variables
let's check which the variables has the
highest correlation with the variable
selling price
looking at the selling price column or
row we see that the local price has the
highest correlation value of 0.79
the living space per square feet
variable is a very close second
having a correlation of 0.789
with the selling price
so the selling price is strongly
correlated with the local price and the
living space of the apartment
as suggested by the correlation of
almost eighty percent
we can see that age in years has a
negative correlation with the selling
price with a value of
minus 0.21
thought the correlation coefficient is
quite low we can see that an increase in
the age for apartments
tend to decrease its market value
performing correlation for all the
variables against all the other
variables is more advantageous as it
compares all the variables and helps us
in getting insights which might not be
visible by just looking at the data
for example we can see that garage count
has a mild correlation with almost all
variables
so the number of garages to be built for
an apartment is quite independent of the
number of rooms or bedrooms or the
living space
however the presence of a garage
tends to have an increase in the selling
price as can be seen from a correlation
of 0.4 with the selling price
now suppose we don't need to correlate
entire table
need to test the correlation between two
variables in such cases we can just type
core dot test and mention the two
variables whose correlation we want to
know
suppose we want to know how much the
number of rooms is related to the price
of a house
so to correlate selling price with
number of rooms we type core dot test of
rooms count comma selling price
here we can see the results to be zero
point five five
from this value we can understand that
there is about fifty four percent
relationship between the number of room
counts and selling price
also the p value is very less which
supports the hypothesis that the two
variables are related
the next test we will perform on the
data is anova analysis of variance as we
have seen in a collection of statistical
models used to analyze the differences
between group means and their associated
procedures
the calculations of anova can be
characterized as computing a number of
means and variances dividing two
variances and comparing the ratio to a
handbook value to determine statistical
significance
here we shall perform anova on selling
price with two categorical variables we
have in the data set
let us first test the means per the
level variable
and store it in a variable called fit
so we type fit equals to aov of selling
price tilde level
data equals my data
now type fit
and we can see the anova result
the first factor we can see is sum of
squares
it is the deviations from the sample
mean
from the anova result between selling
price and level the sum of squares value
is 43 and the residuals is nine thousand
one hundred sixty two
the next factor number of degrees of
freedom is the number of values in the
final calculation of a statistic that
are free to vary
in this case degree of freedom of level
is 2 and residuals are 54.
next type summary of fit we get other
parameters like the mean squared value
f statistic and p value
the very low value of f statistic and
higher value of p value imply that we
cannot reject the null hypothesis
the obtained p value is 0.8 quite high
compared to the standard value of 0.05
when we analyze the levels variables we
see that most of the apartments fall in
the two-story category
this kind of skewness affects the anova
since their number of observations in
each group is highly unequal
let us view this graphically by using
the plot function
type plot of selling price tilde level
gives us a box plot of the selling
prices for various values of levels
we can see that two-story and ranch
apartments have a high variance whereas
split level prices very very little
also for two story there are two
outliers in the data
a similar anova can be done with
material and selling price too
so type fit equals aov of selling price
tilde material comma data equals my data
and we can see the anova results for
material
we see the sum of squares value for
material is
eight 637.88
residuals value
eight thousand five hundred sixty seven
point six one
the degrees of freedom of material is
three and residuals is fifty three
next we type summary of fit and we can
see the other parameters similarly here
even though the f value is comparatively
higher the p-value is higher than the
standard value and hence we cannot
reject the null hypothesis
we will view a similar plot as earlier
by typing plot of selling price tilde
material
the apartments constructed with wood
have a comparatively lesser variance
there are two outliers in this graph as
well
and correspond to brick wood and wood
categories
here we have performed a comprehensive
descriptive statistics on the data and
some inferential statistics depending on
the data we have at hand it is very
important to note that the type of tests
and the statistics that we use depend
entirely on the business need and the
type of data we have
it is common in analytics to be
sidelined from the purpose of the
research or analysis by applying various
tests on the given data
through this case study we have provided
an example of when to apply which
statistic and where to apply different
tests of significance to arrive at
meaningful insights
let's look at an experiment to
understand the use of t-tests
a researcher studying the effect of a
drug on the growth of tumors wishes to
find if the drug reduces the growth of
tumors
the researcher obtains mice with tumors
and divides them into two groups
one group of mice was injected with the
drug
and the other group was used as the
control group
after one week the tumors were weighed
again
and the results were noted as follows
the research question is
does the drug reduce the tumor size
in the given table we can see the tumor
size of mice treated with the drug and
the tumor size of the mice belonging to
the control group
since these two belong to two different
groups of mice and have no dependencies
with each other
we will use independent t tests
let's recall the assumptions for
independent t tests
the samples are random
the measured values on a continuous
scale
the independent variable is measured on
two groups or categories
that is in our case the experiment and
the control group
the observations are independent and
follow an almost normal distribution
there is homogeneity of variations
and lastly there should not be any
significant outliers
since our data adheres to all the above
assumptions we can continue with the
significance test
the researcher wants to know if the use
of the drug decreases the tumor size
hence it corresponds to a one-tailed
hypothesis test
remember that two-sided hypothesis tests
would be used when the research question
is
whether there is a difference in tumor
size as the result of the drug
in the video
we will look at how to perform a t-test
for this study
and if the hypothesis is proved or
rejected
let's start by loading the data set into
r
step 1
make sure the working directory in r is
set to the directory with the data file
using the get wd and set wd commands
step 2 create a data frame tumor data
and read the file using the read dot csv
command
the argument to the command is the name
of the csv file with the extension dot
csv
step three
as seen earlier the head command
displays the first six rows of the data
type
head of tumor data to display the first
six rows of the data
step four
before planning the t-test let us
visualize the data using box plots
type box plot of tumor data to create
box plots of the two columns
the plots are created and displayed in a
new window
here you can see that the median of
tumor size for mice not treated with the
drug is higher than the mice treated
with the drug
also the quartiles or deviations from
the median are higher for the control
group
step five
next let us perform the t-test to find
whether the drug has an effect on the
tumor size
as shown in the previous video the
t-test command is used to perform the
t-test
before performing the test let us attach
the data frame by typing the command
attach of tumor data
now type t dot test of treated with drug
comma not treated with drug comma
alternative equals
l the alternative equal to l is used to
specify that the test is a one-sided
test
and we are concerned about the lower
tail that is if the tumor size is lesser
on hitting enter the test results are
displayed
the t value is given as
minus 2.0643
and the degrees of freedom is 13.651
using these two values the p-value is
generated as 0.02927
the next columns display the 95 percent
confidence interval that is minus
infinity to
minus 0.009
the sample estimates are displayed below
the mean of x and the mean of y
x and y are used to denote the two
columns
here we can see that the mean of tumor
size for the experiment group is
0.675
and the mean of tumor size for the
control group is 0.742
the null hypothesis for this case study
is that there is no difference between
the means of the two groups
correspondingly the alternative
hypothesis states that the true
difference in means is less than zero
with a significant value alpha of 0.05
we can reject the null hypothesis since
the p-value is less than 0.05
thus we can conclude that the drug has
an effect of the size on tumor in mice
and the tumor size reduces as an effect
of the drug
with this we complete the concepts of
basic analytic techniques
now we will look at a business case to
illustrate the concepts that we have
learned in this lesson
let's quickly summarize what we have
we have discussed
a basic introduction to r
data exploration
using r
data visualizations in r
pie charts
bar plots
box plots histogram
diagnostic analytics using r
chi squared test
t tests
analysis of variance
the section will help you check your
understanding of the concepts covered
this includes
three the business analytics foundation
with our tools course offered by
simplelearn
thank you for your attention please
continue your learning with lesson four
of this course